so my grandfather when he was a very
young man a newly married started a
business and about that time the Great
Depression hit the stock market crashed
he lost his business he was blessed to
get a job in Alcoa Tennessee with Alcoa
aluminum back in the day he ended up
working there for 38 years in the
accounting department was one of the
head cost accountants when he retired I
heard the story growing up I didn't
witness it that he had a bit of a temper
can't imagine that in the Ramsey family
and apparently as the story goes he was
at my parents house who were newly
married in their probably 20 years old
with a little kid me running around and
my mom reached to put some leftovers
away and pulled out aluminum foil only
it wasn't Alcoa aluminum foil it was God
help us Reynolds Wrap
apparently he got so angry he took the
Reynolds Wrap and pulled it all out all
over the backyard went through her
cabinets and threw out everything that
was Reynolds Wrap in her cabinets and
said Alcoa aluminum has supported this
family for decades and you will not
dishonor that now is that a little
overboard yeah yeah definitely a little
overboard Ramsey's have a tendency to be
overboard sometimes I I'll go with that
but it's an interesting thing that that
I think is missing today in our culture
this idea that the company that you work
for gives you money
therefore feeds your family allows you
to live your dreams allows your children
to go to school and puts clothing on
them and food on their table and I know
corporate America is not loyal to the
worker and doesn't always treat the
worker great I get all of that but this
is not about corporate America this is
about you and your personal integrity
an element of integrity is loyalty so I
think a little bit of what my
grandfather had a little dose of that
would be good for everyone of us to
remember if you don't like them if you
think they're a bunch of bozos if you
think they don't have integrity if you
think they don't pay enough this is a
free country
quit get out stop why do you keep
working for someone that you think is a
crook and then mistreats people that
says more about you than it does about
them when you no longer trust leadership
when you don't under - cause when you
don't think the product of the service
that the company puts out is quality and
you're no longer proud of it that's God
speaking to you he's yelling at you he's
saying I have something else for you
leave go do something else leave when
your spirit leaves for God's sakes take
your body with it God has a plan for you
he loves you and it's not to bring you
harm it's to bring you hope he designed
you in such a way that you're supposed
to do certain things folks work for us
for a season sometimes sometimes they're
healing while they work for us and they
go out they start their own businesses
sometimes sometimes they move on to
other things
sometimes they decide I'm some kind of
character and they don't want to work
for that kind of character all of that
is fine
the only thing is not fine is staying in
a place that you hate because it says
more about you than it does about the
place hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind